Fox news is doing something that is evil genius.
I have to hand it to them like the it's, it's
actually genius what they are doing.
If Fox news were to say, we're not going to
talk about the impeachment trial, we're not
going to show that there is an impeachment
trial going on.
They would rightly be called out because that
would be completely absurd.
We've had three presidents impeached in the
history of the United States.
Andrew Johnson was in the 19th century before
we had 24 hour news and the internet and satellite
television and all of this stuff.
The other was bill Clinton in the 1990s and
now we have Donald Trump not covering impeachment
would be crazy.
Even for Fox news.
They would be called out.
It would not be something that they would
be able to, to to bear.
So Fox news has figured out a way to have
impeachment on the TV screen, but not to really
cover it and to propagandize directly through
the impeachment proceedings.
Yesterday.
The impeachment managers, the prosecutors,
as they effectively are in the impeachment
of Donald Trump.
They had their first three days of presenting
their case.
It was long.
It was nearly eight of their 24 hours that
they have allocated for this.
It was very nuanced and detailed and there
were exhibits, videos, tweets, text messages,
but Adam Schiff and the others did a very
good job of laying out the big picture of
Donald Trump's wrongdoing, starting to sort
of lay out the arc of it.
Fox news often showed it on mute, meaning
without audio, including going to commercials
while impeachment was going on and they can
say, we covered it.
If you turned on Fox news, there were hours
and hours where you could see that impeachment
proceedings were going on.
You couldn't hear it.
It was on the screen though.
You couldn't hear what was being said.
They ran commercials.
Later, they ran right-wing commentary lying
about the content of the proceedings while
you could see but not hear the proceedings.
So let's look at a few clips.
I have a bunch of these.
Here's a commercial for some kind of bed.
Linen or pillow or something.
When Adam Schiff is speaking about how the
precedent committed high crimes and misdemeanors
and should be removed from office,
each and every one of you get the best sleep
of your life.
That's why I created my new Giza dreams bedsheets.
I guarantee you there'll be the most comfortable
sheets you'll ever own.
Now, every network has commercials.
That by itself is not a huge thing, but this
was all day.
Here's another example of when a Congresswoman
Val Demings was laying out her part of the
narrative and as Erin Rue Parr said on Twitter,
Fox has the optics of covering the impeachment
trial without really covering it.
They show the proceedings with no audio while
the hosts provide Trumpy and spin.
Here's Jesse ladders saying they should call
Hunter Biden to the trial.
You get to call whoever you want and one of
the reasons you call Hunter is ask him what
the hell he was doing over there and why he
was doing it.
That's why he was making that phone call.
Partially the wall street journal wrote, I
mentioned this in an editorial that if you're
arguing there was a corrupt motive that that
Trump have, then if he was investigating Hunter
Byron's activities, well, let's explore that
and let's explore what Hunter Biden told his
father, the vice president about his business
in Ukraine.
Let's ask Obama energy SAR, Amos hoc stain,
who raised concerns about Joe Biden and his
AIDS about Hunter bides Ukrainian ties.
And then there was a Chris Heinz, former secretary
of state, John Kerry's stepson broke business
with Hunter Biden because of his work with
asthma.
He called it unacceptable.
So let's, let's cover all that just really
quickly.
Hey, they covered it, right?
I mean, you couldn't hear a damn word that
was said.
You could only hear pro Trump's spin and conspiracy
theories, but it was on the screen.
You could see Val Demings moving her mouth
there.
Then at night, mind you, this was still while
the proceedings were going on because they
went from about one to nearly, uh, 9:45 PM
Eastern time.
Sean Hannity, instead of showing you what
Adam Schiff is saying, sums up the proceedings
as we learned nothing at all and there's nothing
notable here.
And Adam Schiff, uh, looked like a crazy person
manufacturing consent telling you what to
think after a full day of telling you what
to think.
Here's what you missed from today's Schumer
shift.
Sham show, charade made it again.
We learned absolutely nothing new today.
Not one new piece of information.
Instead, we got hours and hours and hours
literally of the compromise.
Corrupt congenital liar, Adam Schiff.
Wow.
Never ending nonstop fame, moral outrage.
And then here's Tucker Carlson also again,
the proceedings were still going on.
Just ridiculing the entire thing right there.
Send an impeachment trial is still going.
It's been in progress all day.
There'll be forgiven if you didn't watch every
single minute of it.
Imagine a movie written and directed by children
who's ending you already know.
And by the way, it's 20 hours long in Hungarian
with misspelled subtitles.
That's what it's like.
We've been monitoring it anyway all day because
that's what we do and we'll alert you if anything
interesting happens during this hour.
So understand you could watch Fox news all
day and in some technical sense you'd be watching
the impeachment trial except you would have
heard commercials for my pillow instead of
Adam Schiff.
You would've heard Jesse Watters and Degan
muck Powell talk about, uh, we got to get
Hunter Biden to testify as if that's what
this is really about.
And then you would be able to finish out the
day with Tucker Carlson and Sean Hannity spoonfeeding
you that you didn't miss anything.
All the impeachment managers are making fools
out of themselves and there's nothing to see
here whatsoever.
These are full on propaganda tactics.
Okay?
This is how you end up with people who say
Trump did nothing wrong.
Did you watch the trial though?
You would say to them and they'd say, you
know, I did, I watched the trial, but did
you hear anything that they said or did you
see Adam shifts mouth moving while Tucker
Carlson and Sean Hannity told you there was
actually nothing to see here?
Well, no, I guess I, I watched it, but I didn't
really hear anything.
But Trump definitely did nothing wrong.
It's a very sad state of affairs and it's
part of reinforcing when Republicans ultimately
vote to acquit, everybody will feel Trumpists.
I mean that they did the right thing.
A Fox news viewer on the day that the acquittal
of Donald Trump happens.
They will hear Trump was acquitted and will
think back to, you know, I remember watching
on Fox news and I didn't hear anything damning
about Donald Trump during the trial.
Well, Fox ran it on mute while their commentators
told you that there was nothing to see here.
And then they'll think, yeah, the Republicans
voted the right way because I don't remember
hearing anything very damning about what Donald
Trump did.
Manufacturing consent.
It's out of a textbook.
Um, and the story of how right-wing media
is handling this is a huge part of the story.
And when the history of this is written, I
hope that's included with, uh, with Andrew
Johnson's impeachment.
Of course, the technology wasn't there to
manufacturer consent in this way with bill
Clinton's impeachment.
Uh, well that was the impeachment of a Democrat.
So the rules are completely, completely different
when it comes to how right wing media will
cover it.
And of course we didn't have social media
then like we do now.
This is a huge, um, event for the United States
of America in and of itself, but the manufacturing
of consent, the media narratives, the spin
are a huge part of it and we can't forget
that.
Let me know what you think about how Fox news
has been covering this.
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman.
Follow me on Twitter at D Pacman.
Let me know what you make of how the right
has been covering
the impeachment of Donald Trump,